for Allah tell us about the composition
PCP construction everybody thank the
organizers for opportunity to give the
stock I'll be speaking on the role of
composition in low error PCB
constructions unlike the other talks in
this this will only be focused on PC
peas and not to do I won't have any
cryptographic sort of constructions
basis is just construction of PCBs and
primarily it's going to be this sort of
modular con how modular composition
helped and constructing better and
better PCBs in the higher regime this
was sort of achieved by what are these
objects called PCP as of proximity in
the lower
the low error regime this is achieved by
something called decodable PCP and fact
this will be the focus of the talk most
of the talk will be trying to understand
what these objects are and one of the
reasons I'm sort of giving these talks
is not only have these these objects
these sort of sort of modular forms
these sort of PCBs approximately creeper
not only gave rise to the PCPs of play
very low error and all and give a
modular viewpoint of this one they also
led to the current best shortest PCP
constructions known so they both these
cases they give rise to the nearly
linear sized PCPs which is best weakened
so in that sense then these objects
might be helpful even in the towards
what constructing the rest of this
workshop coming coming with short PCPs
this one so what we will study you look
at for the most part of the talk is
trying to understand decodable pcps we
might spend a little time depend on PCP
so proximity is also in fact decodable
PCP sort of generalizes the notion of
PCP is of proximity so just to find out
what's the pieces what's a PCP the PCP
theorem gives a alternate
characterization of NP it says that
anything any proof that can be checked
by a deterministic verifier can be
rewritten in a slightly longer fashion
this NP proof which we'll call the
probabilistic Lee checkable proof said
that the new proof is now verifiable not
by a deterministic verifier but by
probabilistic verify so that's the weak
that's the sort of strengthening or the
verified but the way you sort of rest
when you restrict the verify by making
it look at the proof at a very few
location so it probes the proof at just
a very few locations and is convinced of
the veracity of the proof in particular
if the input was a satisfiable instance
it a member of the language there is one
such proof that can such that all the
local views are accepting local views
for this probabilistic verifier
input is not in the language then no
matter which proof which purported proof
you feed to the probabilistic verify
that most local views are always
rejecting this more questions the focus
of our talk will be how small can we
make how large can we make this most so
is it like 0.1% one
the 1% of the views or more like 99% of
the views can be made look reject in
this sense what is a PCP a PCP sort of a
locally checkable encoding of the NP
proof it's a it's in some sense it is
also an NP proof is a different n people
but it is something which is locally
checkable you can check the feather the
proof is correct or not by looking at it
at very few locations and but where does
composition play a role in all of this
so for that we should understand what
how do we construct such BCPs so
typically one of the most classical
constructions of pcbs today we know
several other constructions also arise
from low degree polynomials these are
one of most familiar constructions of
its and you use this following objective
sort of there is some form function
which I give on sort of a finite finite
dimensional space F to the M after the
function and the claim of this is a low
degree function how does one locally
check this without probing the entire
space you can one now very natural test
is to just pick a random line I check if
the restriction of the function to this
line is a low degree function just using
the main fact the restriction of low
degree polynomials to a line remains low
degree so this is before I'm just
formalizing the test that test is I'm
going to give it with both the points
Oracle which is this function f and with
an extra lines Oracle V we are in the
world of PCP so we can give an
additional proof so I give up the lines
Oracle which as I said which is the
purported restriction which is for every
line I'm going to give sort of the
restriction to that line I'm going to
give a low degree polynomial and the
test is the most natural test you pick a
random line and a random point on the
line query the lines Oracle for the line
the points Oracle for the point and
check that they are equal and the low
degree test which is sort of the
technical core of the proof of the PCP
theorem says that if this clearly
firstly clearly this test has
completeness one if if the function is
in fact low degree then there is one
lines Oracle such that this passes with
probability one but what we care for is
the other direction suppose the test
passes with say 90% prob
can we say that the function is close to
being low degree and in fact the low
degree test analysis owners of the Lodi
various analysis says this is indeed the
case that is if the function if the low
degree test passes that is if I bought a
random point and a random line
containing the point the perl lines
oracle and the points oracle agree say
with 90% probably 90% of the time then
there is a look there is in fact an
honest-to-god low degree polynomial that
agrees with the function on most
locations now using this we can
construct a PCP and fact this was one of
this is what we saw in the bootcamp we
saw starting from such a BC low degree
test we can construct a PCP with the
following parameters randomness log run
query complexity is either poly log n if
you're Melissa restrict a poli-sci
proofs or n to the epsilon if you are
working with nearly linear sized proofs
that's great that's so already the low
degree test gives us this but however we
would want even small better query
complexity in particular if you are
working with nearly linear size this one
this is not good enough for us we would
like to push it drive it much lower and
here is where what we'd like to do is we
would like to reduce the number of
queries and composition is what comes in
as a tool to radius so what do I mean by
that so let's actually look at what's
let's look at this abstract notion of
what I mean by reduce the number of
queries let's look at the action of the
PCP verifier to more closely what is the
piece B verifier do it gets as input the
theorem that it wants to prove and some
external random points based on this it
computes some local window and a local
predicate on the proof it goes looks at
the proof of that local window and then
accepts of that view in the local window
satisfies the local predicate now what
we would like to do is we would like to
check the first two parts don't involve
reading the quilt the second least I
don't know why or they're all one one
one the these two parts are the ones
that are going to read the entire local
view we would like to test that the
local view satisfies the local predicate
without reading the entire local view
this seems very much like what a PCP
does a PCP
checks if a proof is correct without
reading all of the proof so
so it was this like my BFF Aurora and
Safra from 92 which said just compose
use another PCP to reduce this task that
is used if this were the outer PCP use
an inner PCP to sort of check to do this
process don't read all the queries don't
read all the queries in this local
window but use another delegate the task
to our inner PCP which is going to do
this work this is easier said than done
the inner verifier notice that it not
only needs to check that the local
predicate is satisfiable which is what a
PCP is doing a PCP is given a theorem
and it checks if a theorem is
satisfiable or not is true or false
the local predicate there you know
verify not only needs to check that the
local predicate is satisfiable but it
also needs to check that is satisfiable
by what is written in this local window
so there's some sort of consistency
issue that it has to this one and this
is done very delicately in this one and
typically how what we'll show in this
way show that we miss this consistency
issue can be sort of resolved using what
we will define called the decodable PCP
a decodable PCP will be sort of a an
extension of an ion so a PCP which will
help us to do this consistency testing
any questions so far
so what do I mean by a decoder of Appeal
let's start off with a vanilla
definition of Dakota PCP
so the usual PCP is just this it's a
sort of an encoding of the NP witness
you take an NP witness and you it's a
locally checkable encoding of the NP
witness now decodable so PCP is so usual
NP the PCP proof is just a locally
checkable and coding of the NP witness
what I'm now going to add is not only
should this proof be a locally checkable
encoding of the NP witness it should
also be a locally decodable encoding of
the NP witness because in the heart of
this proof is somehow the NP proof so I
want to check if I can extract out the
NP proof using the this one so formally
what do I mean by this and so the the
decoding PCP verifier in addition to its
usual inputs which is the theorem
statement and it's randomness is going
to get a location some index to a
location in the NP proof and it's now
asked to
either if it rejects if it see if based
on a local view of it rejects it rejects
but when it accepts it's not only not
just supposed to accept but it's
supposed to decode what they NP proof
contained at that location so this is
what I want to mean by a decodable pcp
so please this is what the semantics of
the syntax of it should look like it
should it's exactly like that the
irregular verified but it's all in
addition to this given an index in the
NP way the original NP proof and it's
asked to output if it accepts the what
is written in the corresponding and P
location formally what I mean is the
following that is for every NP proof in
the completeness case there must be a
this is what this I'll call it a
decodable pcp rd pcp such that the
verifier decodes correctly with
probability 1 all the time and soundness
what I'm going to say is for every V DP
ad PCP both in the s and in the no case
for every D PCP they must be a valid NP
proof such that the output the verifies
output is consistent with why the notice
that if if the theorem was not
satisfiable there is no valid and P
witness of most of the time there should
be rejecting say what I claim we are
here is a verify should either be
rejecting or whenever it rejects it
should be greater outputting something
consistent with the NP witness for every
piece for every DPC purported proof by
they must be attached with it an NP
proof must be able to extract from it an
NP proof such that what the verifier
what the decoder does on this particular
thing is always consistent with this one
it's inconsistent with that problems are
most very small probability very small
here very small will be like 1 minus
Delta but this yeah
would it be okay to just take a normal
PCP and append to it a locally decodable
encoding of the witness would that
satisfy your definition let's take any
PCP and attach an encoding without doing
any consistency checking between the two
that would not why would that that would
not ratify the
satisfy some so I want to say that trend
so I want to say that whenever it
accepts whenever the what do what this
is for what I wanted to say then ever it
accepts it should be accepting because
of this particular NP witness so we're
so if if this the previously if the if
the proof is this was a if the theorem
was false this would be rejecting most
of the time which will be the case here
too but let's look at the s case the
when the theorem is actually true in
that case that what I want to claim is
every string if any string causes the
verifier to accept with probability more
than one minus Delta that must be
because most of the time I can actually
extract out an NP witness out of that
string that's what I mean so the
probability is going to be over R and J
over here that's good enough for the
applications I have the worst p SJ makes
it like locally decodable codes which we
don't we're going to aim at rates which
are better than what are achievable by
locally decodable codes this is import
so yeah so either I'm going to make it
formal next one so what we're going to
have us in the s case this is what you
have it's always decodes to the valid NP
proof in the soundness case for every
decodable PCP they must be and n peoples
they need not be an NP proof attached to
it such that the probability taken over
the random joins of our and the index J
this should be Jo here probability that
the local window rejects or output
something this should be bounded so
either it should be rejecting most of
the time or it should be outputting
something consistent with this
particular NP proof so it should not be
it should not be accepting and be
inconsistent with the end people that's
all I'm claiming over here so whenever
it accepts most of the time it should be
because of a particular NP witness so
you are tying down every decodable PCP
to
particular NP witness so then if it
accepts its because it has in its belly
this particular NP witness so that's not
implicit in the original statement of
this is V theorem but almost all
constructions had this feature so to get
this out of the existing thing is very
easy so if you can massage all existing
constructions to have this feature and I
want to say once you have such a
definition so almost all IP at least the
look the PCP is constructed on the low
degree test are almost automatically
they do have this extra feature that is
whenever they accept it's because hidden
in them is the NP proof and you can
actually extract out the NP proof you
can formalize this and now once we have
this we'll see how we can do composition
it is because there's a weakness
somewhere but then you can't get out as
likely to see a corrected symbol with su
then yes has they it's not it's not
obvious how to make it this one you have
to do something else so it's easy when
you're working over PCP is constructed
from multivariate polynomials for
univariate polynomials Avensis and so
then it's not obvious but you can
massage them to construct locally
decodable codes locally decoded sorry
decodable PCBs okay given this object
how do I now do composition with it now
there's a very fairly straightforward
thing so what is it let's go back to our
problem we had this proof pie which we
wanted to check so the verifier as
before computes the local window and the
predicate that it wants a computer on it
but it's not now going to actually read
all of it instead of it instead of
checking the local window and satisfying
it's going to delegate this to an inner
PCP it's going to invoke a decoding
verifier so corresponding to each
randomness of the outer one there will
be a corresponding inner proof it's
going to delegate it and that out there
is going to delegate it and pick a
random symbol in this proof and while
checking that is correct it's going to
check that that random symbol is
actually consistent over here so this
ensures the consistency across the two
proofs
so it's this inner PCP proof is trying
to check that this predicate is
satisfiable furthermore not only is it
not sort of is saying is satisfiable the
witness due to which it's satisfiable
it's able to decode a bit in it and then
you just check the breed a random
location and this n check that that bit
kind of matches with what the inner PCPD
codes from the PCP you started off you
will need a robust PCP version but for a
cause
Timms yeah you will need a robust yeah
why doesn't store up the size this is
this is their only per randomness of
this one so it's it's like recursion
it's for you have a you this is for each
of the inner right so this is I'm going
to add the sort of say the original
proof added an N square converted an N
proof to an N square long thing and this
itself was just poly log n this is going
to write a square of poly log in for
every internal randomness and that's
fine yes but every right choice of the
random point I'm going to add proof the
proof will be now this proof plus
several of these proofs but that's okay
it's just a concatenation of these
proofs in that it's okay for polynomial
time and we will yeah you see later on
when you do it to correctly it actually
there is no it just grows by a factor of
a linear factor so that's going to be
the entire compost very fair the compose
very fair just going to invoke the outer
verifier but not read it in all its
locations just going to pick a random
location and as Ron said we would need
robustness I will come to this later for
now let's just assume I'm sort of
cheating over here and going to check
the consistency across these two and
that's going to be the compost verified
one second so the query complexity of
the new compost verifier is goes from
the outer square e complexity which was
fairly large number to the inner square
e complexity plus an additional one
consistency query
any never be yes again from building one
additional TCP that sort of at the same
time checks all of the queries so I
don't know how to do this it would be
good if you could do it but I don't know
so you each one is taking a different
predicate so for each predicate you have
a different for each one is checking if
this window satisfies this predicate we
and and they all not only even if they
are the same predicate they have to
check that this is satisfied by this
particular assignment so each of them is
being given a different task so you're
going to have no but that will not
result but then once again you are
making blowing up the size the whole
point of here is this one this the input
for the inner guy is just it's running
on a formula of this size if you put a
tap on Junction it comes back to the old
input and there's no reduction in the
size right now suppose you the full
point was suppose you had a PCP that had
made square root n queries you
constructed our outer PCP which made
square root n queries you could recurse
on it this will have only fourth root of
n queries because this it has quite out
of n query so it's input size a square
root n so it will make fourth root of n
if I did the conjunction of it I don't
gain any thing and doing it so the whole
point of the this one is to read use the
query complexity so you want to make the
task of the you want to make the query
complexity of this smaller in this
process
the concatenation of all of these tiny
proofs is this query sir I think you
know the principle one could imagine
doing it all at once and you can only do
better because this would be catenation
is true this one yeah if you take the
contact but you can catenation but I
must have a different way of checking
them together in one sure yeah
actually we will see some different ways
of checking the concatenation later on
yeah okay and in fact this out outlined
approach more or less uses PCPs with
constant query complexity logarithmic
randomness and constant error this is
how this was done previously in the
guise of using PC pieces of proximity
but I just mentioned the whole thing
using decodable PC piece and you can do
this question now which will ask us is
how what about PC piece with very low
error I want to get error I want to make
the rejection probability smaller than
half possibly even sub constant this
approach we will see why this so firstly
we should have even decodable PCP should
be very low error PCP so how do we so so
how do we get low error or PCP there are
two options to go about doing it one is
just take the constant error or PCP that
we are constructed do perform peril
repetition on a to query version of it
and you would get PCP switch have great
trade-off between soundness and alphabet
size in fact the optimal trade-off but
the main caveat being here that the
proof size blows up when you use
parallel propagation it goes up honestly
what so what we would like to do is a
different approach in which we construct
such a PCP directly from a low degree
polynomial by passing the need to use
our reputation and hopefully we get the
the hope is out here the process doesn't
blow up as much as panel repetition and
ideally we would like to get the same
trade-off so far we don't know how to
achieve this trade-off between soundness
and alphabet size when we construct such
a low error PCP directly from low degree
polynomials let's see how to do this so
first need to do this firstly I would
need a low error decodable PCP in which
this error now the previously the error
was around 90% that error has become
like 0.1% so I need the exact same
statement as before but with such a low
error over here now if you look at it
this way whatever what do I want here
for every string pie I want to tie it
down to one particular NP witness and
say that it's acceptance is pre or
whenever it accepts it's because of that
particular NP witness now on the face of
it this is an impossible task to do
because I could take the proof which is
in the first part come corresponds to a
PCP from one valid NP witness and the
second part is correspond to piece P
from another valid witness and it will
accept with probability say about half
or one-third so but you will never be
able to tie it to one particular NP
witness there are two NP witnesses which
correspond to this question is we cannot
expect for such a soundness we will have
to write two will have to read the
soundness requirement of such a DP CP
has to be chamber you would need what is
the list decoding version of the
statement we can't tie down a PCP a PI -
oh NP witness we could only tie it down
to utmost a constant number of - a list
of NP witnesses and that's what we will
try to do and if we first see it the
reason is the low degree test actually
has this feature to it
so this was the low degree test which we
said and a refined analysis of the low
degree test due to rosin Safra and
aurorus who then showed actually that we
have exactly the same problem the
probability that the test ox that is
given any points Oracle there exists a
short list of polynomials such that if
the probability that the test accepts
and it's not explained by one of these
polynomials is very low that is whenever
the test accepts it is actually the
reason for its acceptance is one of
these polynomials so this is the refined
analysis of the low degree test given by
them and once we have this we can sort
of change the soundness of the
corresponding decodable PCP will say for
every DPC peopie given pi there's a
short list of NP proofs y1 y2 y L such
that the probability that it rejects and
it's not one of these guys is very low
in other words the probability that it
accepts and it's not explained by one
some element in this list is a very is a
very low probability
so we such a
we see pecan so once you construct a PCP
out of low the low degree test it's very
natural that you will get such a
decodable pcp and now we can go back to
this one you can fast what happens to
come yeah maybe one over Delta or order
one over Delta this just comes from the
fact that you use the Schwartz Apple it
depends on your using the fact that it's
not true for any particular list it's
you uses the fact the low degree
polynomials have distance D over D over
Q this one and we are working with this
is not true for all Delta it's only true
for delta which is polynomially larger
than D over Q so I am sort of fudging so
there will be a so but D over Q will be
set such that that will be vanishingly
small and then it will be just two over
Delta will be the leading term here so
it'll depend in general you can always
show this this is just a so this is sort
of the sort of like that comes from the
Johnson bone or so if you have if you
have a port how many days can fun it
come if totally no overlap between the
different ways you can take L different
proofs and each one Delta fraction of
the entrance yeah so you get Winthrop on
our Delta you get two or delta [ __ ]
let's go back to composition the same
same composition which we had before so
it was this it's just that we have a
strengthened outer and strengthened
inner both of which are working with
very low error this one fine let's just
check if the same composition goes
through what I want to claim is actually
in where bottom this composition goes
through you can do this the only thing
to observe is the error of the compost
PCP will be the error of the inner PCP
inner decodable PCP plus L times the
error of the outer PCP because the inner
PCP says if it doesn't satisfy there
will be L possible outcomes and for each
of them you are asking the error of the
outer one so this is the sort of error
one will expect out of this so once we
have the sort of list size this the
error which you would get where so the
error of the composed PCP will be L
times the list size times the error of
the outer PCP plus delta as long as
Delta and the capital Delta and small
Delta are small this one is small so you
keep maintaining you do composition such
that this composed composition
repeatedly such that this is quantity is
small and you will get a low error PCP
so why is this so intuitive it takes
awhile to prove this intuitively it says
but for probability Delta everything
that the inner PCP returns behaves like
one of capital L outer NP witnesses
that's what the soundness of the inner
guys' and now you have to just say that
these L guys correspond to L different
proofs each of them have an error of
capital Delta and therefore the total
error is the aid of the inner error or
once you fix the theories this makes you
have to sue them together and that took
you have to stitch them there's a
randomized stitching sort of works that
is it works and you get exactly this
it's just the fact that this is the
inner thing and the inner thing was
perfect you have it behaves as if they
were L they were L outer proofs and it's
one of it and it's basically the error
of one of them so you have this but you
have to do this randomized etching that
if you come up with a randomized outer
proofs which is one of these days and
it's a AB so at this point of at this
point of time both this is small this is
small and we will be setting tell is one
on a delta so you'll have to choose
capital Delta to be like Delta square in
a delta inner square and then K recur
use so that they're a total error will
only be two Delta inner so you will
choose outer one with error the outer
one has to be square of this we will
come to this we'll try to see how to get
rid of this yell also later on in the
yeah so if you do if we do a careful
analysis we will see that this actually
gives you logarithmic randomness and low
error PC piece however notice one caveat
of this is each composition adds an
extra query therefore the number of
queries the PCP will make will be at
least the number of rounds of
composition the whole so you will one
will never get such of a to query PCP
out of such an object so what was what
is observed is actually so you can't get
a to query PCP by this so what we will
show is if the composed PCP has this
other property which we call robustness
which ron had alluded to it well define
it now if it had this robustness
property then heat this automatic it is
syntactically a to query PCP I will not
go into what's initial if you can show
that the PCP that we construct has this
extra feature called robust it is
actually a to query PCP even though it
might be making several quarries it
looks at in a different guys it is a to
query PCP and what is this robust PCP so
let's actually go to one it's I'm just
going to change the soundness so what's
the soundness which we had so far for a
regular PCP we said if the string is not
in the language then most local views
are rejecting but we'll just change it
to state that most local views are not
just rejecting we are actually far from
accepting most local views offer in
other words they expected the agreement
of the local view with a satisfying
assignment to the local predicate is
very small this is what so this is what
we call robust soundness it's going to
strengthen the soundness of the PCP and
say that not just that the most local
views are rejecting they are actually
far from accepting formally I'll just
say the expected agreement of the local
view that the satisfying assignment of
the local predicate is very small in the
s case this agreement is one in the know
case that I want the agreement to be as
small as so this is what we will call
robust pcps question is do robust pcps
artifact stronger criterion in fact
almost all the PCPs that construct on
polynomials do have this feature
question which you would like to do is
this composition pre so because of this
property both the outer and
if you're constructed or wrote of
polynomials they will be robust question
we would like to ask is does the comp
composition preserve robustness when you
have an outer which is robust and inner
which is robust there's the compost one
also have low robustness so let's
actually go back to our composition and
check if it's robust so is this the
robust PCP yeah single query so you'll
have to an cutoff you have to be a
little careful distribute the queries
that is a call these are in two
different alphabets so assume they are
the same alphabet then is it robust I
want to say this can never be this can
never be robust because the look comes
the compost view always consists of two
logical parts one part into the outer
and one part into the inner and each
part individually you can change it this
make it's satisfying use therefore the
robustness can never be smaller than
half say either any one of them so yeah
as long as you have this sort of logical
break if the proof is broke if the come
to proof of the compost very very fire
which is the outer proof plus the
concatenation of all the inner tools it
has sort of such a logical break down
then you're never going to be it's never
going to be robust so what we will do is
we want to fix this around so we'll go
to one of their ideas of trying to check
the different inner provers
simultaneously why were why did we have
the outer prove are at all in this
because you wanted to check that the
inner tours are consistent with each
other instead of checking it against the
outer prover we'll check them against
each other rather than checking them to
the outer promote formally I just wanted
to say this since instead of decoding
from the inner proved and comparing it
to the outer proof symbol compare the
inner proofs to each other so you break
this sort of logical split in the
compose provers viewpoint so what we'll
do is suppose this were the outer proof
this only now is in the mind of the
verifier there's no there is no nothing
written down it picks a random location
in this proof looks at various windows
that that proof location participates in
looks at all the corresponding inner pc
peas
runs them and asked them to decode that
symbol and then just checks if they are
all equal so the outer PCP is completely
disappeared it's there only in the mind
of the verifier it picks a random
location in it pick various views that
part it participates in looks at all the
corresponding inner deep ECP's and then
ask them to decode the same value and
checks if the values decoded are and
that's going to be this one and it's not
hard to show that this actually
preserves robustness this doesn't have
query complexity reduction as good as
the previous one the query complexity
goes from the outers to D times the
inner where D is then sort of the degree
of this the number of local proof number
of local views that this location
participates in but as long as this is a
reduction we are achieving a query
reduction but on the other hand this has
the extra feature that it is robust
sampler will suffice
you just pick a good sample and in fact
if you do all views this will not be a
reduction because you look at it if you
construct the PCP out of low degree this
is like a point and I'm going to pick up
all lines or planes that contain the
point that's way too many so that D will
be too large if if I do this on the PCP
constructed out of the low degree test
like is it like we know at this point at
this point of time instead of going over
all the this ones you could just use a
sampler to generate a generic sampler at
this place so instead this at this very
step instead of saying all windows use
some more extra randomness to pick use a
sampler to pick the certain number of
windows and do it that would have
sufficed but the error so what you would
do what would happen is the a you will
get a sampler error over here so just
this will give you this year or the same
error as what we had before if you did
it with a sampler you will have a
sampling and the sampling error will
enter it will be this plus Delta plus an
ETA which is the ETA coming out of the
sampling error
any question and once again this guy's
question is sort of valid here what's
the intuition why is this true it's the
same you do the same thing that is but
for probability Delta all the inners
sort of behave as if there are they are
l outer guys and then you could come up
with a fictitious outer this one which
is a randomized the decoding of these
yell outer guys and that you'll show
that satisfies with probability it needs
the K delicate analysis but that's the
you get exactly this answer
and so if you actually perform this
repeatedly you'll obtain the sort of the
sub constant theater PC P of Moskowitz
and Ross who show that for every
alphabet Sigma and their error Delta
which is 1 over log is making the the
alphabet size there exists a nearly
linear to query PCP over the alphabet
this way so what we have shown so far is
that actually this gives you a robust
PCP with certain properties I didn't
tell you how what's the translation
between a robust PCP and a to query PCP
but for this talk let's skip that a
robust PCP by its definition almost is
the to query PCP is just a robust
converted to query PCP in which one
query asks the entire view and the other
query asks a random location in it it's
the usual transformation from AK you
prove MIP to a to prove MIP but if it if
this Q prove MIP was robust then
actually this translation does not have
any loss in soundness usual loss and so
unless if you go from AK you prove er
sorry that if you say if you go from a3
prove MIP to a to plover MIP the
soundness will deteriorate it cool if it
was the original gap of 1 minus Delta to
become 1 minus Delta over 3 there'll be
a reduction but if the soundness was
robust then there won't be any reduction
and that's why we wanted the whole thing
to be robust in this and because of that
we'll get at to query and this nearly
linear just comes out as a and added
this 1 that is we are not do this is so
modular and this one there's hardly any
extra randomness added so if the
original outer and the inner we're
nearly linear there is no extra addition
more or less you will get a nearly
linear sized PCP in the whole process so
this is in the in the result of Moscow
its rows it's n times to power log into
the epsilon so this is an multiplicative
factor of exponential and log n to the
epsilon
it's not n poly log n it's it's better
than any n to the 1 plus epsilon but not
n poly log
so this is great we can using just this
decodable PC piece on this idea of
composition we can get such good this
once notice the panel repeated PCPs have
a much better trade off they actually
had a trade off in which the error error
was inverse polynomial in the alphabets
size not inverse this one and this is in
fact what's the famous is the
long-standing open problem the sliding
scale conjecture which says that you can
more or less achieve the same thing with
a better error performance the error is
inverse polynomial in the alphabet size
rather than inverse logarithmic this is
what this is the water what a parallel
repeated PCP will achieve except it
won't have nearly linear size the size
keeps blowing up here we do get nearly
linear size but with a weaker dependence
on alphabet this once the question came
you can now ask can we get sort of a
better trade-off between these two yet
maintaining the PCP is to be shot we can
ask further this can we further reduce
the error that we obtained
so let's actually try to we won't I
won't be able to fully answer this we
won't be able to get it we still still
this is still open we don't know how to
get ava constant query PCP that has this
feature what we will show is we will get
more or less such a rate this one if we
allow the queries to be slightly super
constant in fact we allow it to be log
log n we will get district we will be
able to get this trade-off
okay
so let's go into where did the error of
the robust composition arrive from so
the composition had this sort of error
it had the error was L times the outer
error plus the inner error this was the
error of this one and this L the factor
of L appeared due to the list size of
the inner D PCP and if you're doing a
constant number of compositions this is
okay and as I'm going to point it out if
you do super constant this is going to
blow up in fact it's going to be if you
do T levels of composition you'll
eventually have an L to the power T and
this can become this one of the reasons
why the the these PCP is over here don't
have as good a trade off one you can ask
can we get rid of this yell over here
can we come up with a composition which
will sort of get rid of this particular
can we get less size one we saw that we
cannot get less size one we cannot pin
down a decodable PCP to a single proof
decodable piece will always it's such
small error it'll always talk about it
will have L different things but can be
still let's see if we can what I want to
do is avoid the sort of the sort of
something that looks like the Union
bound you that comes arises because of a
factor of L over there where did the CL
come from a TI came from the L came from
the fact that any points or a kill would
have capital some a small list of for
long low degree polynomials which would
explain the full success of the test so
this is where the L came from so that's
basically we had that equality whenever
the low degree test passes it is
explained by one of the El Pollo no
means except with probability Delta and
that because it can be explained at one
of the else as they're sort of a union
bone that goes on here and you get this
factor L but notice the fact that it can
never be the case that it has explained
by several L but each randomness each
line could be explained by one of the L
but each line could be more or less
explained by just one yell if it agrees
with one polynomial it's very unlikely
to agree with so the Union Bowl is
extremely wasteful over here that is for
each L I don't know which of the L
polynomials it is if I mean should I not
use the same letter L same from this one
for each line yell I don't know which of
the capital L pollen
mewls that it agrees with but it at best
agrees with me only with very few of
them typically only one of them we want
to sort of capitalize on this we want to
sort of say that because of this we can
further refine the decodable PCP and say
that we're not going to lose a factor of
L better once so so what will we do so
and this is because of Schwartz Apple
they okay please explain back more
typically one utmost one polynomial so
what we'll say is we now change show
that because of this observation we'll
show that we can construct a decodable
PCP with a better this is not a better
with a sort of a slightly different
soundness
definition which we'll call
distributional soundness the previous
soundness was the following that is
every PCP PI D PCP pipe you can tie it
down to a short list of n P proofs such
that which fully explain the acceptance
probability a the probability that it is
not one explained by one of these NP the
decoded value is not one of the NP
witnesses or reject is very small now I
want to say I don't have a list over
here but actually exactly one from this
I can't do this so what we'll do is
we'll do the following that is I won't
know which element of the list status
but in general but if I know which line
I am talking about over here which line
I am talking about I know which element
in the list I am going to be so
basically we will say that there exists
a short list of NP proofs but there's a
mapping from the randomness of the
decodable PCP to the list such that the
probability that the local views they
passes but it does not agree with that
particular view is very small so it's
not one of the elements of the list but
it's exactly why this particular thing
which is actually so this is not a dip
it depends on the PCP and their choice
of randomness each different random coin
could have a different element n P proof
that explains it
but you once you're picking up the
randomness you're saying this is the NP
proof that explains the local view and
so this will sort of help you to get
over the multiplicative factor of L and
D analysis so you just redo the same
composition theorem which we did before
but now do a super constant number of
compares
patience you will get sort of a
refinement of her earlier result due to
denote Fisher Kindler Ross and Safra
basically we get a polynomial that makes
very few queries super constant but very
few poly log log and queries in which
the error is 1 over polynomial but the
alphabet size is so they have nearly a
polynomial dependence in fact it's
better than a polynomial dependence
their soundness is better than 1 over
poly in D alphabet size that's because
we are making super constant number of
can you say a word about why this
property improves so it's just the fact
that in this composition I will no
longer have
this capital L know little B Delta plus
Delta know it's a dowel I've burned so
when you're doing a sure the constant
number of compositions as or or a few
compositions has done either in the old
result or an NMR result this will not
really affect the error but when you're
doing a super constant number the error
is like previously it was like L to the
power T and that should you say it
worried about why the new property the
distribution all lets you get rid of the
air I mean you didn't explain the status
analysis for the previous one but why
does the fact that kind of local views
[Music]
so sort of tell you in these sort of
soundness analysis when you sort of
doing this randomized thing for each
particular thing you will check which
random you you're looking at and you'll
be able to decode according to that
particular day this one it's a no no
it's not an easier argument it's an
order the composition in this so this is
the composition which guy I fell funny
it had its composition once you set up
everything this one it still takes about
three pages or so to show syntactic but
it takes about it's non-trivial to show
it you basically get rid of the L in
that this one if you have the if the
inner PCP has the stronger soundness
it's not easy to
yeah actually it's not easy for me I
won't be able to abstract it out this
one it just point-of-entry
shaves off the L factor here and you
will not notice this l factor if you are
just doing the constant number of
compositions so it's both these will do
you will have to do a super constant
therefore you will have to do this other
this one therefore we will have this you
won't get it it would have been great if
it we won't be able to get it at the
level of constant queries will only be
the own you notice this difference when
we have poly log log n queries and at
that point you begin having this sort of
this sort of abstraction out of
decodable PC piece so the fact that we
could have built previously we had this
notion of PCP approximately which led to
nice composition PCBs sort of replacing
them a decodable PCP so this to be
honest lets you give cleaner proofs not
just cleaner to sometimes it actually
improves on parameters heavily and it
has the advantage that not only gives
you the lowest error pcps that we
currently know but also gives the
shortest pcps that just came for free in
this process that is these things don't
did not add any extra randomness and so
we got the shortest PCP constructions
[Applause]
never petition to share why PCP is in
proximity why these do better than this
piece of proximity does have to do it
so the proximity is sort of it's tying
you down to one through proof you work
with more the PCP of proximity it ties
you down with one proof and in fact the
way PC piece of proximity bear
constructed with you construct a
decodable PCP and just check robe a
random location and check that this one
so that already had tied you to one and
this one lets you it's just the fact
that this allows for less decoding of
the proofs that one did not
intuition of what types of barriers
separatism size scale is it question of
more refined composition or better
ingredients - right now I think this is
my advice to you but I think the
ingredients have to be improved we more
or less got that the put them together
in the best way possible and I don't
know how to push them together so we
will need something that improves on the
English so basically we had this
reed-muller based pcp the harder math
based pcp and then the one coming from
the newest gap amplification these are
the three building blocks and we've been
doing them and think be more or less I
don't know we would need to improve on
one of these allowed us to get the most
out of the primitives that we know yeah
yeah but to get the full side in scale
you really need new primitives new codes
that are much more efficient yeah we
would need something better than read
code which has better rates and
reed-muller and look has but still has
the local testability features of
reed-muller can you phrase like a clean
coding question that implies the sliding
scale conjecture given the composition
techniques I don't know how to phrase it
that way because one question of courses
you want locally testable codes with
there's a question of locally testable
towards with constant rate linear
distance and consequent testable that's
one thing it's unclear because if I'd
say it's a reed-muller codes come with
the advantage that they have polynomials
you could encode computations in
polynomial so I don't know how to
abstract this out for an arbitrary code
as if it had this extra feature then
possible but I don't know how to
abstract this polynomials have this
magical property which been using wall
throughout here
the questions
let's take it brother good breaking I'm
thankful guys